as walt disney said
if you can dream it
you can do it
now what makes me laugh as i know right
now some of the people listening to that
they say that's [ __ ] they're just
limits to what humans can do
[Music]
and i get that response i understand it
i used to respond to everything like
that i used to see only the difficulty i
used to see only the ways in which it
couldn't work out and i couldn't see i
was literally blinded by fear i was
blinded by some bizarre sense of pride
that wanted to justify my limited
existence that didn't want to have to
face that i could be doing more that i
couldn't be more that my life was
somehow less
than what it could be
and so i would laugh at quotes like that
and i know right now of the chills i
know right now
there are people that are laughing at
that and all they can think about are
the limits all they can think about are
the things that prove him wrong and
guess what he is wrong
there really are limits
but if you
waste your time focused on that you're
never going to create the momentum that
you need to actually make something come
true in your life you can build
virtually anything but if you get hung
up on the
virtual part if you let that stop you if
you
immediately go to the things that
ultimately limit you and hold you back
that is where you're going to stay
forever because if you argue for your
limitations guess what my friend they
become
yours
and congratulations you now get to live
in that box you get to live in that
self-defined prison but if like teddy
roosevelt said instead of that you keep
your eyes on the stars and your feet on
the ground and you don't act like
somebody who can't see that sure there
are limits there are edges to this
universe
but you're looking not at that
you're looking at how do you really
execute you're dreaming big and you're
remembering that your feet ultimately is
that contact point it is where the
rubber meets the road it is that moment
of doing
and so if instead of rejecting it
because your feet must stay planted on
the ground remember that in keeping your
feet on the ground that's the moment of
action that's the moment of doing
something about it that's the moment of
seeing the possibilities and then
moving
doing something making it real so right
now give up on those weird mental
mechanisms that make you actually want
to fight for the things that aren't
possible to get people to believe in it
to get people to understand why
you've chosen to stand still
instead of that convince yourself that
you should be moving and go do what you
know you're destined to do
unreal how much time you waste during
the day and most of it is on these
computers phones
you know instagram and back and forth
whatever the heck you call it nowadays
tweeting and texting this
we waste so much time on our little
gadgets
it's unreal and we tell that we have no
time if you really take you have to take
your day
and write write down this one day
everything you do write that down and
you're like my god i am wasting so much
time on frivolous [ __ ] not even
funny i mean it will it will it doesn't
infuriate you
it should
because there's so much time i can't get
it in look at your schedule you just
wasted seven hours today on [ __ ]
i mean you don't have an hour a day
to try to get something in for yourself
i guarantee everybody can find an hour i
don't follow people who talk about what
they used to do in life
look at what you used to do
i don't care like you know you used to
be the basma i don't care what are you
doing today
you may not be that person now but what
are you still doing to try to excel in
life
and a lot of people now are talking i
hear so much talk
i don't hear a lot of work i hear a lot
of people telling you what you should be
doing how you should be doing it how you
should be living and i look at him and
you're fat you're out of shape you look
like but you're telling them how to live
no man i won't listen to you
there's so many people speaking this
and that's what bothered me a lot in the
military
there's a lot of people talking
i don't see the real suffering behind it
behind what you're saying that's why i
said man you talk with so much passion
because it's a real place
it sucks to get up in the morning
there's rain like cats and dogs i want
to get my shoes on go run but guess what
i got my [ __ ] on and ran yeah got that
fear is like is the vision that's coming
into my mind
is j is jake lamotta at the end of
raging bull when he's all fat and he's
staring at himself and in his own lack
of accountability mirror right right
like drunk and talking about the good
old days right there are no good old
days man
no no good old days
you gotta you gotta go back and use it
for strength man but it's where you're
at now there was this one morning
where um
i
walked into the bathroom
and i was standing in my underwear
brushing my teeth in front of the mirror
and i looked up at the mirror and my
first thought was
uh
i
noticed that my jowls were starting to
look like saddle bags on a pack horse at
the grand canyon
and uh i had like these crazy lines by
my eyes and my neck was really like kind
of saggy and one boob was hanging lower
than the other and my gray hair was
coming in and i and as soon as i started
kind of critiquing my
thoughts
my looks and appearance then my mind
rich started going
i didn't get that email back to that
person and i got that presentation i
need to do and my god did that speech
just cancel again what the [ __ ] am i
gonna then i look down and the dog needs
to be walked and then i think i got a
zoom call in nine minutes like i gotta
get my [ __ ]
and before i knew it my whole mood was
low i felt overwhelmed i had taken
myself down mentally
i just wanted somebody to walk in and be
like mal you it's gonna be okay like you
got this girl like it's lift your head
up you can handle this
i don't know what came over me rich
this is
pathetic
but standing there in my underwear
in front of my bathroom sink
i raise my hand
and high five my reflection
and i cracked a smile because it's so
[ __ ] corny
i even thought of that guy stuart smiley
from the snl skips remember that i'm
nice i'm kind people like me
went on with my day
that was it
snapped a photo though no not that one
oh not that one not the first time and
then i kept doing it i did it probably
for
a week or two and here's the weird thing
about it i started when i woke up after
doing this high five your own reflection
in the mirror thing
i actually started to feel like i was
looking forward to it
and here's why you know i've spent a
lifetime just like you standing in front
of the mirror and what i realize now is
that when i'm standing in front of a
mirror i'm either critiquing
or picking myself apart
or i'm ignoring myself
and when you start to high-five your own
reflection
it starts to build a partnership
within you with yourself
when you walk into the bathroom and you
see your reflection and you've been
greeting it it's like seeing another
person it's the strangest thing you
start to realize how often you [ __ ]
ignore or destroy yourself when you see
yourself or beat yourself up be all
in that was one of kobe's favorite words
when it related to winning he says you
have to be obsessed with whatever your
win
is and everybody looks at
that word obsessed as a bad word
as a bad word but
look at this if you weren't obsessed
would you have the guests that you have
listen how many people do you know
you just did an interview recently with
was it tony tony and um tony robbins
russell brand yeah all right
well if people want to hear what they
have to say you have to be obsessed in
order to get that information for the
people that aren't obsessed absolutely
otherwise they want to bring the
information to me
right
so they should be thankful that man
you know what
we're really really thankful that lewis
is obsessed at doing what he's doing
because it brings us enjoyment it allows
us not to be obsessed in that area and
we can be obsessed in some other area
how many times have you had somebody say
to you have you got a minute but
you got a minute
they don't want a minute
i want you to think about that
i read a poem one time i said i have
only just a minute
only 60 seconds in it
it was forced upon me i can't refuse it
i didn't seek it and i didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it i must
suffer if i lose it give a count if i
abuse it it's only a tiny little minute
but eternity is in it
well anyway i thought i'm going to put
this on a video and i'm just going to
share with everybody just this one
little part of the seminar i'm making
i want you to look at this sand timer
and let this i want you to think about
your life the sand in the top of the
glass represents the future
the sand in the bottom of the glass
represents the past
now do you know we know what's in the
past and yet we can't do anything about
it do you know what the trick is you
don't know how much sand's in the top of
the glass you may think you have a lot
you might only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when i was a little boy i was raised by
my grandmother
and i don't know when i was little
gaffer she was probably 60 but
as long as i could remember grandma
would say and i'll soon be glenn dear
i'll soon be gone well you know we loved
her she was really an angel of god but
we thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94 for 30 some years
i'll soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left
now about the same time i had a buddy of
mine bob yates he was just 16.
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out
if you had asked him a half hour before
how much sandy had left he would have
said at least a half a century he didn't
have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left
the future
we don't know the past it's gone now the
only thing you can deal with is what's
right here right now and if you look the
sand is always moving
now think of this
you see i was working on that and then i
was working on a graph i've got here on
my computer
and i'm thinking of the time somebody
said have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute
do you know if you're earning 50 000 a
year in minutes 42 cents
a half hour is 12.50
if we take that ahead a bit if you're
earning eighty thousand dollars a year a
minute sixty seven cents
half hours twenty dollars
if you're earning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute
it cost you a dollar twenty five a
minute
a half hour's 37 dollars and 50 cents so
do you see how somebody said you want to
stop for a cup of coffee
well
if you're earning a quarter of a million
dollars a year
a minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hours 62.50
and then of course you've got the coffee
to pay for on top of that
so you see
the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now
we don't know how much we have left in
the future but we do know what we've got
now and i have found the people that win
are the people who make up their mind
they're not going to waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
going to make it happen
every minute play to your own element
don't try and perform someone else's
expertly
so in modern terminology how would i say
that is
don't waste your time steve jobs don't
waste your time trying to live someone
else's life
you know don't be trapped by dogma
focus in on your own strengths your own
element what you have to offer don't get
lost in trying to become like someone
else or pretend to be someone else
there's a beautiful one of my favorite
quotes by einstein and then steve jobs
again einstein said if you judge a fish
by its ability to climb a tree it will
spend its whole life believing that it's
stupid
and too many of us are fish trying to
climb a tree too many of us are monkeys
being taught how to swim too many of us
are lions being taught to live like cats
we're not getting to live in our element
so my second piece of advice is live in
that element that you've naturally been
given don't try adopt another you know
we've all got a special genius inside of
us it was steve wozniak and steve jobs
this conversation steve wozniak looked
steve wozniak for those who don't know
is the tech guy behind apple he
practically invented the technology and
the software and everything so steve
wozniak looked at steve jobs and he says
this is in walter isaacson's biography
of steve jobs steve wozniak wozniak
looks at steve jobs and he says what do
you even do he said you're not a coder
you're not a designer you're not a
marketer and you're not an engineer what
do you even do imagine challenging steve
jobs and steve jobs replies he says
he says musicians play their instruments
i play the
orchestra that is the most deep
understanding of one's role in life and
not getting lost in other people's
identities and perceptions of you steve
jobs knew that he wasn't a marketer he
wasn't an engineer he wasn't a coder so
he hired all of those
but he played the orchestra he brought
it all together
and that's when you when you find
confidence in your own role you won't be
envious of anyone else
i was in my early 20s and i developed
this incredible arsenal of tools a
toolbox a tool test if you will of the
very best tools to create change rapidly
things that look like magic to people
where i could take somebody and i would
go on a radio show or a tv show and i
would challenge traditional
psychologists and psychiatrists and i'd
say give me your worst patient i don't
care if they have uncontrollable phobias
have them come see me i'll handle it in
one hour and i developed this idea that
i was the one hour the one-stop coach
the person that can help people make any
change and i built my career by actually
doing that i got on television and radio
and i took people with lifetime phobias
and turn them around these are all just
techniques and strategies that i didn't
develop i just kept looking for the best
and i kept synthesizing it and bringing
it forward so when i started out here i
was this guy helping people lose 30 60
90 in some cases 200 pounds or taking a
guy that was barely surviving
financially and within a couple years of
this
counseling or coaching as i started to
call it really got him to turn his
business around and literally got him
financially independent
relationships that were falling apart
and i i learned the distinctions to help
couples change and so when you start
getting those types of results that are
that measurable people started giving me
attention and the media started to come
to me and then what they wanted to know
is this what are you you know and i
thought are you a guru i said no no no
no no not that you're mr motivator like
no no i i'm certainly believing people
having an inspired life
and think about it inspiration is pretty
important if you're not inspired what is
inspired it means in spirit means
there's an energy in your life if you're
not inspired about your life what do you
have nothing but
i'm really more about strategy and they
kept pushing me guru motivator what are
you you know
and i said well you know what i really
am i'm a coach
and i came up with that metaphor i mean
there's always been consultants in
business i wasn't talking about
businesses it was individuals
and i said i'm not a therapist you know
i said and i don't have a degree
people pay me because i produce
measurable results they pay me nothing
unless i do it that's how i set up my
career that's how i built my brand and i
said you know for me coaches are people
that not better than you are a coach
just has a different perspective i mean
even back in those days the best
athletes in the days the gretzky's the
michael jordans etc they all had a coach
still to this day the best half coaches
because the coach can see what you can't
see because you're in the force they're
outside of it
and i know as an athlete i was better
than some of my coaches but they made me
better
so i said that's my job i'm a coach
because to be a coach is not better
they're they're a friend they're they're
an equal they're there for you there's
somebody who cares deeply about your
well-being but they're also incredibly
skilled to help guide you at the moment
you really need it
and so i started promoting this idea of
being a coach and
you know the sports metaphor helped some
people but the media didn't buy into it
very much but i was able to succeed
finally because i was able to keep
measuring these results i mean i would
go out and say i'll come see me for one
session i'll handle this problem or you
pay me nothing and you can check it out
for 60 days i still use that formula to
this day as many of you know with my
products and services so what was really
fascinating though was along the way i
was there's a point after years of
calling myself a coach and there's no
coaching industry nobody talking
themselves as coaches i remember at one
point i hit a point where i was about to
give it up and larry king even said to
me on air one time he said you know what
is this you're you're a coach what does
that mean and i was trying to explain
peak before it's coaching and strategy
and so forth and and right about that
time suddenly coaching became the term
of art and everybody was a coach
therapist started calling themselves
coaches you know uh financial planners
became coaches it just became the term
of art so it's been a fascinating
journey watching that word come in
because what i did is i helped build
that term by making it based on real
results in our mind we start to realize
that we're concerned we're afraid we
don't have enough i'm not safe i'm not
secure
and i say oh these thoughts i was
talking about the thoughts in your mind
go in and control your biology your
genetics your physiology and your health
and i go yes this is really true
i said well how can i tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can i read
your thoughts and i say yes you know i
could put wires on your head and it's
called
electroencephalograph and i could read
your brain activity and i go oh great i
can see this brain activity
i want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were
programmed to believe that our thoughts
are contained in our head
that if i have a thought it's just for
me not for anybody else it's inside and
it's working through me
and now i want to tell you about a new
technology it's not electro
encephalograph it's called magneto
encephalograph i say what's unique about
that i say read your brain i say yeah
but so does eeg i say yeah but eeg you
put the wires on the head and you get
the electrical activity conducted
through the skin from the brain and
that's what i'm reading and i said
what's different about meg
the probe
is out here
and i said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head
your thoughts are broadcast to the field
just like a radio broadcast
i say well what if i as an individual
have a thought that says
let's have peace in the world
and i broadcast out there in the street
and i say let's have peace and i look
around it's like
where's the peace i don't see the peace
and here's what the relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field i say your energy is in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go what does that mean and then i'll
give you this most wonderful quote
i used it the other day in a lecture
from albert einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field
so definite definition the field is the
invisible energy right now you're in a
field there's cell phone broadcast
television for television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field
the quote
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
particle is the material realm
so what was einstein saying
it's the energy in the field that shapes
the physical experience of our lives
and if enough of us collectively have an
energy that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast a belief we change the world
i just want you to recognize as much as
i wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if i want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced
that the war is going to benefit them so
that their broadcast say yes let's have
a war because i and my colleagues we're
all going to have a better result from
that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share
thoughts
and yoga
when you're in your postures when you're
in your process your mind is sharing a
thought not just in your head
but all around you
so the whole idea about this is we have
to recognize
we are collectively
creating reality with our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking
you get enough people to say peace there
will be peace instantly in this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to
give them the power to tell us what we
need
and assad fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and i really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field
and that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore
what this world is looking for at this
moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough
it will end
if you live your life based off the
opinions of other people you will never
do anything great take a look at who
you're worried about people who are not
happy with their life people who never
went and took their shot people who
spend their life complaining instead of
trying to change something is that who
you want to be so worried about what
they think about your decisions if
anything you want to do the exact
opposite of what they're telling you to
do you don't want their life so stop
living your life by their rules so i had
an amazing one-on-one with an
entrepreneur yesterday at my q a session
here in toronto that i do weekly
and i feel for her she's such a talented
amazing gifted entrepreneur
and we talked about your purpose coming
from your pain and she went through some
massive pain that guided her to the
success right now and on her path to
personal development but she's afraid to
share what happened
and she said maybe in a year or two like
give me a year to work on and maybe i'll
share it because she's afraid of what
people will think she's afraid that if
it doesn't work out that she may not be
able to get another job she's afraid of
all these things that people might say
about her if they found the truth
problem is that's your path
i don't care about what where you're at
right now i need to know where you've
come from i need to know that you look
like me i need to know that your story
is like mine
and so by living in the shadows and
being afraid to tell the truth what
you're doing is one not letting people
connect you as a real person right this
fake perfect version of you isn't
something that people can connect to two
you make it so that whatever you went
through it you're telling yourself that
it's it's shameful
and you're telling other people that
it's shameful too but if you come out
and talk about what happened then the
people who feel ashamed about it they
now can come out and say huh i'm not the
only one
this happens to other people too i'm a
little bit more normal and three if you
want to build a business if you want to
create a youtube channel if you want to
have a podcast you want to be an author
you want to write a book that's the
thing that's going to actually help take
you off
that's the thing there was a great video
that i told her about about a woman who
gained 70 pounds
from having a child so she's pregnant
she gained 70 pounds
and she had a 10 pound baby and now she
had 60 pounds of extra
fat on her right 60 pounds so
that's a lot and so she's trying to lose
and she's working out and she's eating
healthy and she finally gets down to
having a six-pack abs and looking great
and then somebody noticed that when she
bent over
that that they could see the flaps of
skin when she stood up it was all
six-pack but when she bent over there
was flaps of skin
and what most people would have done is
deleted that video pretend like it
didn't exist not talk about that
comments right only show the perfect
version look how much weight i lost but
she did something different and said she
said yeah
that's my body now that's what happens
when you gain 70 pounds in pregnancy and
pump out a 10 pound baby
and that became a rallying cry that one
moment of vulnerability of saying hey
i'm still not perfect like look look at
this saggy skin that i still have
that's what brought people to her now
she's not just another mom who lost
weight and did this workout plan and
meal plan right that that connection was
real and now she's built a million
dollar plus business from selling
e-courses and her recipes and everything
else that she goes through that's the
thing this is your competitive advantage
your purpose your pain your story is
your competitive advantage i do not want
to learn from you until i know that
you've been through what i'm going
through
i can't relate to that story right i
can't tell that story i can't tell uh a
mom who gained 70 pounds how to lose
weight that's not my story i can't
relate to it but helping entrepreneurs i
can because i struggled and i suffered
and i was making 300 a month and i was
eating the same bean salad lunch every
day and i celebrated with only
mcdonald's french fries because i
couldn't afford to buy it
all of it i struggle with with fear and
embarrassment and and shame
all of it i know what it's like i've
been through that and why i do what i do
now is because i want to try to make the
path a little bit easier for the next
generation of entrepreneurs for you i
want you to feel like you're not alone i
want you to feel like there's a place
you can come to with a beautiful
community a believe nation where we're
supporting each other and there's
content every single day across multiple
channels that you can go and digest and
dive into and hopefully hopefully
hopefully make your path just a little
bit easier because i wish i had this
when i was getting started when i was a
19 year old entrepreneur who was
insecure and and ashamed and embarrassed
and not willing to talk to anybody about
the problems i was going through
right that's the thing that will connect
people to you but if you're so afraid of
what people's judgments are going to be
you're never going to get started i
believe humans are built to serve you're
built to serve you want to help other
people it's hard wired into us studies
show that the impact of serving other
people has the same effect on your brain
as food and sex it's hardwired into you
you want to help other people
and at the same time you're afraid of
judgment so how do you help other people
if you're also afraid of judgment it's
it's having your foot on the gas gonna
break at the same time you know you're
capable of more but then you're just
standing on the same spot it's the worst
and so you have to let go of the
opinions of other people some people may
not like what you're doing that's okay
that can't prevent you from service that
can't prevent you from fulfilling your
mission that can't prevent you from
living the life you want because you're
going to be 95 years old looking back on
your life and regretting it knowing
you're capable of more but never taking
action so how do you better deal with
criticism i'm going to give you a
three-step process step number one is
have empathy have empathy
if you believe like i believe that
humans are built to serve right we're
built to serve that if somebody is being
critical and negative when they are
built to serve
how bad does their life have to be that
is forcing them to act this way how bad
does somebody's life have to be to come
to your youtube video and leave a nasty
comment or to tell you to your face that
you suck and your idea is never going to
work how bad does their life have to be
so have some empathy like their life
sucks
and they're lashing out not just you
everybody around them so have empathy
when you have empathy it removes the
sting out of the words right now it
doesn't touch you as much because if
anything you feel sorry for that person
you don't have to say hey i feel so
sorry for you you don't need to go and
make it worse or have go on an ego trip
but just know inside have empathy feel
sorry for them and not let it hit you as
hard when they're giving you some
criticism about your idea or you number
two is look for a gem a lot of times in
the criticism there's actually something
you can learn from a lot of times when
somebody criticizes their idea or lose a
nasty comment on youtube
you might just write it off with that
person's being a hater maybe they are
but there might be a kernel of truth
there might be some gem in there that
you can use i think a lot of people are
too sensitive i think if you can only
take feedback when somebody sugar coats
it and packages it nicely and say i love
you i love your channel i love
everything you're doing i love all your
ideas but there's one little tiny tiny
thing that i think if you fix would
really help if that's the only way you
can take feedback you're gonna lose
you're gonna get nasty comments and some
of them are just pure haters and it's
their own problem but sometimes buried
within that nasty comment is actually a
kernel of truth there's a gem in there
for you and so if you can remove the
sting right have empathy remove the
sting then look at the comment and see
is there anything from this comment is
there anything in this critique that i
can actually learn to make my idea or my
concept better look for the gem and then
number three is address to those who are
dealing with their parents who might be
your biggest critic i understand that
your parents are pilgrims your parents
are pilgrims your parents come from a
different era
if you're 20 years old right now as an
example the opportunities available to
you using this
are things that your parents at 20 years
old can't understand the opportunities
available to you right now are insane
compared to what your parents had when
they're at your same age and so when
they're saying
go get a safe job go be a doctor go be a
lawyer go be accountant go be go do
something you can work at some job
forever that's actually their version of
love for you right that's empathy
empathy step into their shoes they love
you chances are your parents love you
i hope but chances are they do and so
they're trying to give you advice that
they would have given themselves x
number of years ago back when they were
your age
they just don't understand what's
available right now a lot of times a lot
of people who are critiquing you
criticizing you it may be out of love
they just don't understand the path that
you see they don't understand the world
that we're living in right now they
don't understand everything that can be
created
and so have that empathy for them
understand that that's where they're
coming from they love you and again
removes the sting out of the words and
then you can see
how do you want to act
how do you want to react to these people
around you that would make you feel
proud whatever that is in your head then
go and do it discipline yourself and so
what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline
like get up early in the morning and get
your things done man learn to get up at
six in the morning and you'll be one
deadly creature especially if you can
get to work you'll have half your damn
day done by the time other people haul
their sorry asses out of bed and so
that's a massive massive advantage look
will ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tie
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine and then learn
to use a calendar like google calendar
most of you many of you out there do not
use a calendar okay a calendar is not a
prison and it's not a tyrant not if you
use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a that's hell that's a
bad outcome so unless you want that
don't aim for it
and or aim for the opposite because
that's how you get out of it the most
powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle very close proximity that
live at a higher temperature in that
area than you do for example in your
faith let's just say you're a 75 degree
or in your faith you've already seen
this you can't possibly begin to
regularly associate with good godly
people who pray regularly who try to
live righteously and there are 110 120
degrees of of faith in their life and
not have that proximity heat you up now
you won't get to where they are you'll
get to somewhere between where you are
at 75 degrees and they are at 110 over
time you become 100 degreer and you
alter the thermostat setting through
association same in business if you and
i were to hang around each other every
single day and let's say you were a 75
degree or in business hypothetically and
i don't know that about you but let's
just say you were
and i was 150 degree and we hung around
each other all the time don't you think
through that association right
especially if you had two or three or
four people like me in your life that
just over time you don't even feel it
you're at 80 you're 85 you're at 90
you're at 95 and that's where you are we
understand the power of this with our
children
because we know at school the teachers
have influence over them they're mentors
but the people that really have
influence over our children are their
friends because they're around them all
the time and so we know it's that's
their temperature this is true in
fitness if you're a 75 degree of fitness
at every meal every day at the gym all
your associations hypothetically
speaking we're with someone who was
shredded and fit the way you wanted to
look at 150 degrees you know over time
you get heated up and so you can't be
with someone every day you can't be with
them all the time but the key is to get
more proximity in the areas that matter
with people whose thermostat setting is
higher than yours i am a product you are
listening to me right now because i've
been so obsessed with this concept of
adding new associations to my life that
live in the areas that i want to improve
in at higher temperatures than me it's
my obsession to this day i'll give you a
secret one of the reasons i even do my
show is i know that i'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
i'm obsessed with the power of
association but i don't just associate
see
all personnel says yeah you're the five
people you hang around
kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time
of studying them of observing them of
asking questions of the fact that you
should be altering your thermostat
setting that's when it really moves it's
not just hanging around it's consciously
and intentionally spending time with
people
where you allow it to impact you where
you study them where you really observe
them where you're open to their
influence there has to be a level of
trust before you can do that where you
surrender yourself to them but it's not
just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of association is the main way to do it
we both grew up in tacoma
and there used to be a thing called
toastmasters i don't know if you
remember toastmasters but toastmasters
was a local regional and a national
speaking group for anybody that wanted
to get better at speaking
well my dad had gone to a toastmasters
early on and heard one of the most
successful magazine entrepreneurs in the
world speak he comes back and tells me i
just had a chance to hear one of the
most successful magazine entrepreneurs
in the world
speak and he said when are you taking
your sat i said i'm taking it next year
he said well this guy was failing out of
high school he was struggling he was
raised by a single mom in the midwest
but he promised his mother he would take
a test called the s.a.t
so he takes the s.a.t in may's junior
year doesn't expect anything get to
score back in june now the s.a.t which i
don't know how many your population know
but it's it's a standardized test with
the math part and a verbal part both are
scored out of 800 points well this guy
takes it he's bombing he's failing out
of school he doesn't expect anything as
he's telling the story of toastmasters
well he gets a 1480 out of 1600.
so he's stunned right that would be for
the smart people that listened to your
product yeah right cognitive dissonance
i got a 900 on my sats just to give
people a friend
and i got a 10-10 right i was just hey
four digits it was a miracle right and
and but it's a hard test and it you know
it's a variety of different things so he
gets the score and his mother doing what
any mother would do knowing her kid says
did you cheat right she knows her son
and he said i swear to god i tried to
cheat but the way the numbers were and
the scantrons and the bubbles you
couldn't cheat so she says you mean to
tell me you really got that score he
said yeah i got the score so he's
stunned tom so as my dad telling me the
story i'm like okay so he says all right
so what he decides is because he
realizes he's smart and he's going into
his senior year he says i'm going to go
to class
now he starts to go to class he doesn't
hang out with who he did when he didn't
go to class all right teachers see him
in class and they said hey maybe
franklin pierce maybe we missed the boat
on this kid so they start to treat him
differently well as the guy would tell
the story he graduates goes to a
community college goes on to wichita
state goes under the ivy league and
becomes this massively successful
magazine entrepreneur so i said okay
well the guy was always smart he just
needed a standardized test to unlock it
my dad said no that's not the story this
is what i want you to understand
he said 12 years after all this guy's
success he gets a letter in the mail
from princeton new jersey doesn't think
anything about it the next day his wife
says you're going to open it he opens it
true story turns out the sat board will
periodically review their test taking
procedures and the policies the year he
took the test he was one of 13 people
sent the wrong s.a.t score
his actual score was a 740 out of 1600.
and he said people think my whole life
changed when i got to 1480. but what
happened my whole life changed when i
started acting like a 1480 and what does
a 1480 do he goes to class
well this is one of the first stories i
would share when i had my opportunity at
alabama or florida state or georgia so a
your language is powerful but number two
your behavior is way ahead of your
success
and so many people let their feelings
dictate what they do as opposed to throw
your behavior out there russell wilson's
510 he shouldn't be playing pro football
but he behaves like the best quarterback
in the country and he's done that since
before he was at that level and then his
feelings and emotions and his skill
caught up to that behavior i think the
lesson my dad was trying to teach me
ultimately was in addition to my
language what i do
not how i feel about my past is going to
determine who i am in the future and
that's what i think neutral thinking is
i think neutral thinking isn't just
thinking i think it's behavior and i
think it's language and so your behavior
is what's going to change you
but
you also have to start by asking
yourself what do i want and why do i
want it why don't i have it
you know what am i willing to do to get
it health as a lifestyle now i grew up
you know eating a lot of crap i mean i'm
just gonna be honest i ate a ton of
sugar i ate a ton of junk fried foods
you know we'd have like eight cans of
coke or pepsi or sprite every single day
and thought it was actually hydrating us
you know i just didn't know any better i
was eating pasta and chicken fingers and
pizza every single day
and tons of milk i mean i was having
eight glasses of milk
probably as well half the time growing
up i used to have a 5
gallon
commercial
metal milk dispenser in my bedroom
believe it or not for a year i was
living as a
boarding student in st louis missouri at
a private school
and in the dorm room i asked them if
they could put a container
of
refrigerated
milk a five gallon bag we'd fill up
every single week and just crush that
thing every single day just pulling it
down like you're in the uh the lunchroom
and
i was always like well i'm just gonna
burn all this off i'm healthy i'm skinny
like nothing is affecting me i'll be
fine until i could hardly ever breathe i
was always out of breath i had a stuffy
nose constantly
i always had inflammation and pain in my
joints and i wondered why and it wasn't
until later in my life when i discovered
information about nutrition in the body
and really
decided that i needed to shift things
you know i stopped playing professional
football got injured and i gained about
35 40 pounds
and i could notice it you know i was
chubby in my cheeks my face
you know i had like marshmallow face
they called me fluis for fat lewis and i
started to really feel the effects
you know i remember one day i looked
down and my underwear was rolled over
like it folded over because my belly was
pushing out so much that my underwear
was now had rolls
and i remember that moment i was like i
need to shift this like something that i
thought about growing up
and the way i've been living my life
around this idea of my mindset isn't
working anymore so let me find a new way
to shift it
and
i really think about
health as a lifestyle now not as like a
diet or like i can do what i want
sometimes and then change what i want
another time it's really about a
lifestyle
and the health is either hurting us or
helping us achieve the life we want
and everything comes down to
um if we're healthy or not you know
nothing else really matters if we're
sick think about it if you've been on
your bed for a week or
on your couch for a week you miss work
you miss school you can't go do any
activities you can't be around your
loved ones because you're sick you're
sick you're coughing you're in pain
you can't move you'll do anything to get
over the sickness to get over the pain
and sometimes when we get out of the
sickness we go back into our old ways of
routines which get us back to being sick
again needing to be on medications
needing to be
having low energy throughout the day
always being behind your health is
either hurting or helping your dreams
and
i learned this about
i don't know almost eight years ago
seven or eight years ago when i really
started to dive into educating myself on
nutrition
and lifestyle living it like a lifestyle
it's very challenging to break a habit
you know for
25 27 years i just ate sugar every
single day i mean i would have candy
bars just for lunch i would have six
candy bars and call it a meal snickers
there's got some protein in there some
peanut butter right i was just like this
thing is all good for me
and i was addicted to the sugar and
still today it's an an addiction of i
crave it all the time but when i shift
my mindset around this is either helping
or hurting me for a greater purpose in
my life for a greater vision in my life
when i shift the mindset and think of
something bigger than the pleasure of
right now of having that sugar rush or
sugar high or whatever it may be and i
shift it towards
the mind of the future of the mind of
something greater that i'm thinking
about of something i want to achieve
or how i want to show up for people or
how i want to inspire people or how i
want to live a long time
pain-free so that i can do the things i
love when i start to put my attention on
my dreams and aspirations
then my mindset is able to push through
any of the
desires of wanting to have bad food many
people come to me and say i want to be a
millionaire i i and there's a great song
about i'm going to be a millionaire and
they read things like the secret which
says if you want to be a millionaire
just just wish it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school i
was going to be a nanny that's how much
i thought i could earn in my lifetime
that's what i thought i was meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one you don't
believe you are worth it you may want
money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must
decide you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out and make
a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
on my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way it's not about
shall i invent something i don't have an
inventive mind i'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a multi
multi-million dollar company they didn't
invent a new product well they sort of
did they took an existing product they
made it so much better
and you can do that too but the biggest
blocks i see with budding millionaires
are these things one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well one of the reasons
depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestations from sit at home and chan
om
and money will fall from the heavens we
all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to man you what could
you possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her floor you know this is not
really a good mop and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and you said
something i always remembered do not die
with your music still inside you and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get out a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something and some of the smartest
people create things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template and i'm going to
follow that template and if you have the
belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire i spoke at an education
summit for microsoft i also spoke at an
education summit for
apple
at the education for my at the education
summit for microsoft i would say that 70
of the executives spent about 70 of
their presentations talking about how to
beat apple
at the apple education summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite
and the other one is playing infinite
gets which one gets frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you
this thing was spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular i absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was
bright and gorgeous and fanta it didn't
work on itunes which is a different
problem so i couldn't use it but but it
was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant so i'm
sitting in the back of a taxi with a
very senior apple executive sort of
employee number 12 kind of guy and you
know i like to stir pots so i turned him
i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zoom
and it is so much better
than your ipod touch
and he turned to me and he said
i have no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse
the goal isn't to be the best every day
the goal isn't to out to out do your
competition every day that's a finite
construction if i had said to microsoft
i've got the new ipod touch and it's so
much better than your zoom they would
have said can we see it what does it do
react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play
to be better than themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today
than it was yesterday how can we create
a product
this week that's better than the product
we created last week we also have to
play the infinite game it's not about
being ranked number one it's not about
having more followers on twitter than
your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself
it's not about selling more books or
getting more ted views than somebody
else it's about how to make sure that
the work that you're producing is better
than the work you produced
before you are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy
because the joy comes
not from comparison
but from advancement you might have a
great mindset positive thinking but if
you have a heart set full of anger if
your emotional life is sad if you're
disappointed from the past if you
haven't done that the sweat lodges and
the journaling and the body work and the
affirmations to really open up a heart
set then you can have
the mindset of elon musk you have the
mindset of a steve jobs you can have a
mindset of a kobe but you're going to
sabotage yourself from world class and
to me this is the great myth of positive
thinking you see a lot of people they
read all the books they're positive
thinkers they've got the vision boards
nothing changes why because
subconsciously
there's this wounding
and a lack of deservability
and it's unconscious and so they haven't
done the work or you may have not done
the work to make the
wounds of under observability and
scarcity and the low self-worth that's
why positive thinking alone does not
work this is to me a revolutionary
insight and by the way a lot of the
people who
teach positive thinking in the past
are men
so it's very male mind
and a lot of the people who are pioneers
of heart set
are women
heart
empathy
healing
and so
self mastery to me
and this is a pioneering model that i
teach
at personal mastery academy it's not
just mindset that's only 25 of self
mastery and as you know self mastery is
the dna of outer mastery you're never
going to perform higher than what's
going on within
mindset is only 25
heart set
your emotional life working from
confidence and love
and service
and that sense of internal freedom is
only another 25 so those two are only 50
there's a third interior empire you want
to get to world class which is health
set
working on your energy your nutrition
your daily exercise hacking your
longevity eating the right supplements
getting a massage every two weeks you
know my two massage protocol
doing your 60 minute nature walk every
week so that your
health set is at world class but that's
only 75 percent of the equation towards
self mastery you have a great mindset
great heart set great health set but if
you haven't worked on your soul set
turning down your ego you know you know
what disease and what energy depletion
is caused by your ego beating you
relentlessly about you not being enough
and seeing your industry peers
succeeding and you feel insecure and
irritated and angry and jealous well
where do you do that work within your
soul set the fourth interior empire
and as you do that you turn down the ego
and you open up your humanity and you
open up your spiritual life and you
become more soulful and then you release
work that is artistry versus just to win
in the next few months when you
literally give your life over to a
mighty mission that is larger than your
ego and you literally start to see your
work as a ministry for the benefit of
humanity and if you literally if you're
an artist or an entrepreneur or ceo
manager or coder a doctor or a fighter
firefighter but literally if you saw
your work as your poetry and your
artistry and you were on a mighty
mission that was larger than even your
your ego
and yourself
what would the caliber of your output be
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag
believe down in the comments below on
this video i will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
if you want to start your day right
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there the most
powerful weapon you will ever have at
your disposal if you really want to make
change
is knowledge
it doesn't mean going to school it can
be school it can be books it can be a
mentor it can be